hey youtubers is Charlie so a whole
bunch of Game of Thrones stuff happening
just an update on what's going on with
them filming they still have a lot of
stuff left to film especially like their
big battle of the bastards style episode
of the season and reexamining Daenerys
is visions because the TV show might be
giving Jon Snow
some Aegon stuff from the books so just
careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened so far here we go
so lately is a lot of cast tend to do on
really long shoots with really awesome
producers like everybody that gets along
most of the main cast were seen hanging
out at a soccer match just having fun
you can get a little teaser here for
your own versus Tyrion I can only
imagine how they're going to contain all
the sass I don't know how much Tyrion is
going to be on the battlefield in season
7 he's not so much a fighter as he is a
battle planner but there are a couple
big locations that the Watchers people
that camp this set spotted everyone
filming at almost every main cast member
meeting that they're getting ready for
like the really big battle of the
bastards level episode filming stuff the
Lannisters the forces of the crown into
nurses forces so keeping the dream of
cleganebowl alive both of the claw game
brothers were spotted in the same area
now they weren't punching each other in
the face or anything like that but
everybody was filming scenes in and
around what is doubling for the dragon
pit so they're around King's Landing and
then separately they moved to Spain to
much more open area to film this battle
stuff or to get ready to film this
battle stuff so it just seems like one
of the big big battles of the season is
going to take place around King's
Landing which I feel like was inevitable
but I do like the idea that Jamie's army
has been giving it as much as they are
going to get it from Daenerys as forces
so if you remember some of the hype
around the big Battle of the bastards
episode in the work that went into
filming that the crazy number of horses
they'll probably do another behind the
scenes video just for that just because
it seems like it's going to be one of
the if not the biggest season 7 action
set piece and the thing is is that
because this is so far south they
haven't really been any white walkers
seen on set
you know usually that requires a lot of
green-screen but they have been scouting
locations for
season eight which is like way over in
Sweden where there's actually a lot of
snowfall on the ground so what they've
had to do is they've had to find some of
the castles that are in and around sweet
or the places that look like they could
double four castles where it snows a lot
so they're almost a year away from
filming that stuff that season eight
stuff they're just kind of scouting
locations or potential locations for
where they would film where winter has
come south of the wall so if you live in
Sweden and you live somewhere that looks
like it could be like a really awesome
old castle they might be filming near
you next year one of the big holdups
filming in Spain this season was that
they had to wait to look out a lot
colder so that they could show the
change of seasons even further south in
Westeros near King's Landing the reach
the places where thus far on the show it
has always been summer so while like
pictures like this don't really tell you
much about what's going to be happening
they just let you know that we're going
to be seeing a version of battle of the
bastards in season seven with the
Lannister forces into nurses forces but
then eventually this will all move
further north it'll start looking more
like Daenerys as visions back during
season two the cool thing about Daenerys
is visions if you haven't seen that
episode you know season 2 episode 10 if
you haven't seen it they changed a few
things from the books so I'm just going
to run down the list from the books
because it sounds like they're slowly
making things happen from Daenerys as
visions obviously in slightly different
ways most of the visions themselves have
been expressed as metaphors on the TV
show but they're about nine things
starting with her brother's gruesome
death that was something that had
happened in the past at all Lord with
copper skin and silver gold hair beneath
the banner of a fiery stallion with a
burning city in the background this was
supposed to have been the potential
future of her baby Rae go with Khal
Drogo the future that might have been
had things gone differently that's kind
of how the visions in the house the
undying work some things that happen in
the past some things that could happen
in the future and some things that might
have happened had things been different
so the next one was the dying Prince she
sees a dying prince probably Rhaegar
Targaryen muttering a woman's name with
his last breath rubies flying from his
chess
that there were rubies emblazoned on his
armor like you know Targaryen dragon in
rubies so that's what they meant about
that the woman's name probably Lyanna
Stark now this was happening up at the
Trident the Battle of the Trident where
Rhaegar was killed by Robert Baratheon
but the next vision was a blue eyed king
who casts no shadow which was probably
Stannis Baratheon raising a red sword in
his hand the light bringer or the sword
that he called light bringer number five
a cloth dragon swaying on poles amidst a
cheering crowd
just like a Targaryen banner as everyone
cheers now this is where the TV show and
the books might differ a little bit
because a lot of people take this to be
the rise of the mummer's dragon Aegon
but on the TV show it could represent
Daenerys as sales the Targaryen sails
swaying in the wind
so just remember TV show changing some
of the visions from the books a great
stone beasts take swing from a smoking
tower breathing shadows now this seems
like more of a book thing the character
Aegon that they've cut out of the TV
show thus far the idea of like a dragon
waking from stone is more of like a
metaphor for the revealing of a hidden
Targaryen identity so you can think of
it as Jon Snow - but I think you know
because this prophecy comes from the
books it's more talking about Aegon and
when they say breathing shadow fire it's
more a metaphor for treachery just
talking about Aegon trying to seize the
Iron Throne for himself
Daenerys is horse trotting through grass
to a Darkling stream under a sea of
stars talking about her in the Dothraki
sea then a corpse standing at the prow
of a ship with bright eyes and gray
smiling lips this is talking about
greyscale and is more stuff from Aegon
storyline because Jon connington who's
kind of like a gods keeper contracts
greyscale so this is all stuff that the
TV show is cut out but then the last
vision this is always like the big one
that everyone gets really excited about
or got excited about before we knew that
Jon Snow was confirmed to be coming back
but it's a blue flower growing from a
[ __ ] in a wall of ice filling the air
with sweetness so a lot of people took
this as a metaphor for Jon Snow's true
parentage just because the crown of blue
roses that Lyanna stark wore that was
given to her by
rhaegar targaryen just kind of like this
super metaphor for what's happening up
at the wall in the idea that Jon Snow is
going to be very important to that and
that he is the son of Lyanna stark and
rhaegar targaryen so you have like a
whole bunch of things all thrown into
one the Nights Watch mutiny against Jon
Snow Melisandre brought him back it all
happened up there so he is the blue rose
that bloomed at the wall but for the
most part a lot of this Aegon stuff the
show has not done yet now the show like
cut the character out but there's a lot
of rumors that it's going to give part
of that plotline Gendry style to Jon
Snow like it's going to combine the rise
of another Targaryen air which is kind
of what Aegon is and even though it
seems like Jon Snow will be working with
Daenerys eventually they might have some
drama with that storyline like Jon Snow
reluctant king of the north tries to
reconcile what's going on with Daenerys
in his Targaryen heritage but that all
assumes that bran has made it south of
the wall and explain to them what's
going on along with Samwell who will
probably find some information in the
Citadel that helps support that claim
the important thing to remember though
that that actually almost seems
secondary to what's going on with this
giant battle with the Lannisters because
all the characters already have their
motivation Cersei is a terrible person
they want to get rid of her Daenerys
really wants to get rid of her but I
think some of this Aegon stuff will help
bind Jon Snow to Daenerys they'll find
some common history together and that
might help strengthen their alliance but
that says nothing for what
Littlefinger's gonna do about all this
because he definitely wants to throw a
wrench in anyone else claiming the
throne besides him but he hasn't been
seen on all these big sets you know
we're like most of the main cast is
meeting together so he might still be up
in the north when this is all happening
but let me know in the comments do you
think you know based on Daenerys his
visions in the show trying to bring
those about slowly do you think that
we're going to see Jon Snow get some of
the Aegon stuff the waking stone dragon
when the show did a lot of the Gendry
tricks storm plotline it blew through it
really fast and I think it's going to be
one of those storylines from the books
that they change a lot so it'll be a lot
of fun to compare
what happens with a Gon's character when
wins the winner drops when the book
drops with what happens on the show
during season seven because it seems
like it's all going to be happening
around the same time because season
seven pushed by a couple months so won't
premiere till the summer just gives
george RR martin a little bit longer to
get that book out but congratulations to
this week's giveaway winner tristan
williams you win a $20 Amazon gift card
be sure to private message me on the
back end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there is a new round
that starts now all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video there's still a
bit of filming left to do but if there
are any special bonus videos that you
guys want me to do just let me know in
the comments I'm still going to be doing
weekly Game of Thrones videos till the
season premieres which I know seems like
a long ways away but they will probably
drop some teasers early next year some
more behind the scenes stuff just
because the scale of what they're doing
is so big so even though there's less
episodes each episode by itself is
getting much much bigger much more grand
so if you really like those huge huge
episodes like battle of the bastards
there's going to be a lot more stuff
like that in the next two seasons so
what's going to happen is is they just
revealed a whole bunch of stuff on the
flash in this some more Young Justice
that I'm going to be posting so that'll
post later today where you guys wait for
that to post you can click here for my
reaction to the supposed Game of Thrones
spoilers I don't think they're all true
and you can click here for all my Doctor
Strange Easter eggs thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you